one of my favorite people on the planet
and that's the way we're welcoming on
the mercedes-benz vans phone line uh do
you do you think the the these uh dr
pepper contestants should be forced to
throw overhand desmond
what do you think i think that's a good
argument i think that's a good point i
believe that yeah you should have to i
mean because that's the whole point of
throwing a football right i mean you
don't chess pass a football you throw a
football i mean
so yeah
i haven't really heard people debate
that but yeah i'm on i'm i'm i'm i'm on
board with wait a minute
never chest past you the ball never once
that never happened
but these quarterbacks now they have
like this this
jet motion that goes in front of them
and snapped the ball they just pretty
much taps they tap the ball that is a
chess pass right right it's just that
it's just that they're not throwing it
into a a can that's tempting correct 10
yards timing of it has to be perfect too
see now chris that's that's why
desmond's next level right there
how are you jess how are you doing
oh
man listen
bruh i mean look
if i was doing anybody had to put me in
a straight
jacket like that you know what is just
hide it you can't hide it right i mean i
i know what it feels like for me being a
longtime fan and observer what about a
guy like you who has won
a heisman trophy for this school and has
won big games for this school and is
sitting on the set of one of the most
watched college football shows in the
history of such things over the last few
years what is this like for you to see
this you know what it is be rich to be
completely honest with you is it's just
i'm happy for the coaches the coaching
staff and the players you know because
they've been through so much and i was
talking to um i was at the game and uh
talking to
one really popular music music exact
name steve stout and steve stout said
yeah well you know you guys are
ready to get rid of hardball i say well
you know steve the thing is like those
of us who actually know what's happening
we we never really felt like that i said
it's just like you you know you've had
all sorts of musical artists right i say
but you know that there are artists that
that have great potential but then there
are people out there in the media who
are sitting out there and they're
carving up this art this artist
but you as a as an exec you know what's
happening behind the scenes why this
artist just might not be reaching his
potential
just yet but you don't give up on the
artist i said so when i put it in a
language like that then he understands
exactly what i mean about
that's the noise outside but people who
were inside understand what was really
happening
wasn't really as quick to give up on
coach harbaugh and so i'm happy
that the decision makers
didn't pull the trigger because we see
decision makers all over college
football pulling the trigger
haphazardly on some of these head
coaches but they didn't pull the trigger
they stuck with them they made some
adjustments they made some changes and
now a team that wasn't even picked
to finish in the top three i think they
were picked to finish fourth in their
own division
is picked as the number two team in the
nation now who saw that coming i didn't
yeah exactly so that that's so the point
is i'm just so happy for the decision
makers for coach harbaugh and for those
kids who've been dealing with so much
for so many years to be where they are
because they kept fighting the good
fight and they stayed on course and it
has paid big dividends for them so far
and it's going to pay even bigger
dividends for them down the road and
then how about uh the blossoming
uh of
one of your teammates kids into a
heisman trophy
candidate which i think aiden should be
what is that like to watch a kid of a
teammate do what he's doing for the
school uh
that's insane again you know you're so
happy for the kid rich cause don't
forget now this is a kid who
last season was going to be i think
projected to be a first round draft pick
and then he you know broke his ankle and
then you know he's crying and people
like well should he come back should he
just you know rehab and go to the nfl
and this kid made a commitment you know
to himself to his
teammates to his coaches to come back
you know why he wanted to come back he
wanted to come back to finish the job to
win a big ten championship with his team
and he came back and did not only that
now he's like a top five pick and he's
um you know i i and hopefully i'll see
them in new york right saturday so i
mean it it's just a sweet sweet story
and uh got a lot of credit and chris is
his dad who i played with and man what
was just a wonderful man he is and his
wife and what they've done raising um
aiden so just
kudos to them as a family i'll be honest
i can't believe this is happening
you know i always hoped
it's dez you know i had you on when the
show my first show was first beginning
seven years ago i had you on i had steve
hutchinson no relation um and and i had
uh woodson on and i'm like we got to get
harbaugh we got to get him and i
remember i looked at harbaugh when he
was on the sideline of the ravens
years ago when he was um
either at stanford or it just was going
to stanford and he was running off the
field on a saturday night because the
college football season was over and he
was wearing a ravens gear he was on the
sideline of the i think it was the night
that the ravens closed down old texas
stadium and he runs past the set and i'm
like you got to come home man and he
smiled at me and nodded me and ran into
the tunnel because this was what i was
envisioning i didn't think it would take
seven years
to be honest but i can't believe it's
happening
dez i cannot believe it is happening and
it is the greatest thing i said it's the
greatest fall i've ever had and i know
you you're professional and you know i
can be somewhat here because my job is
to actually talk from the heart my gut
from the show the fact that they beat
ohio state
and deny notre dame a seat at the table
i'm not done yet i'm not done yet
and tell michigan state you know with
their big win and it was a tremendous
win for them tell michigan state hey
that was a peach of a win enjoy the
peach bowl
and that was just all it was all it was
is just one of those character building
moments on on our journey
uh to maybe the greatest
season in the history of michigan
football
it's the greatest thing this is the
greatest fall i've ever had my kids were
not born in the fall i wasn't married in
the fall this is literally the greatest
fall i've ever had this is amazing
yeah no it's amazing and it's it's
incredible to watch this journey unfold
the way it has and like you said you
know he was the one that everyone wanted
and things didn't shape out the way we
we anticipated and
we you know people started to make all
these
jokes about michigan and harbaugh and
people coming down so hard on him and
like i said it would have been easy easy
to just fire him you know if he was any
other school like you know if this
happened down in columbus he had been
going years ago because you know this is
just a different breed down there in
other places too but
um they stayed the course they made some
changes they understood what was
happening behind the scenes and um
look at them today so
kudos to them espn's desmond howard
college game days desmond howard here on
the rich eisen show did the committee
get it right one through four seating
him the way that they did they got it
right um
it's hard to say i mean my my when they
asked me
my top four michigan was number one
um alabama was two georgia was three and
uh since he was four that was my own
personal um feelings towards the the the
order but you know they they put bam up
there it is it's hard
to
knock that one
bama and michigan were you know to me
flip a coin it was you he had a strong
argument for either because
you got to give bama credit for doing
what they did i mean not only did they
beat the number one team in the country
i mean don't forget georgia's like wide
of the y regular season like the best
team in the country
um the best defense in the country and
for them to go and carve that defense up
the way that they did
was it was incredible i mean it was like
like the michigan ohio state game you
left that game with
a clear understanding of which team was
the better team it was no doubt in your
mind who was the better team when you
left the sec championship game there was
no doubt in your mind that alabama was
the better team it wasn't like ah man
you know they kind of got lucky and man
if they played again you know it was
like uh you know they they had a bad
call no no no no no
alabama was the better team so
with them knocking off number one you
know they had a hell of an argument so
that's what they got denied okay and so
um what do you think i had lincoln riley
on earlier in the show desmond and i
asked him about this
signing period this december 15 signing
period and if that should be moved
because you know we're seeing all of
these schools oregon just lost their
coach oklahoma lost their coach um
obviously notre dame lost its coach
and and these coaches you know do not
look very i mean the look is so bad for
them to leave right when they're leaving
and and and then kids are decommitting
and then recommitting like that kid who
who did exactly that to recommit to um
lincoln riley here at usc
why why is the signing period when it is
and do you think it should be moved what
do you think of that now that is i don't
pay that much attention to high school
recruiting and i don't know why they
move this i i mean i'm just keeping it
honest i have no idea why they removed
the signing period um what did
i would be curious to see what lincoln
riley would say about it because that
that affects their lives tremendously um
yeah he said he said he'd be in favor of
moving it that's what he said he'd be in
favor of moving it because it's just
those are the guys to really answer that
question those head coaches because you
know it affects their lives and it
affects the um the lives of these kids
so but i have no idea why they moved the
signing period i you know i just always
find it kind of interesting
that people want to look at when
to hire a coach and when not to hire a
coach
based on the signing period because my
thing is you know that's just one
signing period
you you you're hiring this coach for the
some sort of longevity not just for this
signing class you know i mean like to me
i i just don't get
trying to maneuver the hiring of a coach
around one signing class
i'm in for i mean i'm all about the long
game
okay if we lose i mean if this is my guy
this is my guy so if he doesn't get this
recruiting period of this this class and
everybody he wants in this class so be
it at some point you gotta coach people
up too and you got the you got the
transport portal there's just other
things involved where i couldn't make
that the most important criteria in
trying to figure out if i'm going to
hire this coach now or not does that
make sense richard it totally makes
sense desmond and i think it just puts
everyone in a very difficult position
and it it i i i don't understand why
school presidents are cool with it
or why uh athletic department
administrators are cool with it like
they're cool like this would never
happen in the nfl where somebody goes to
another nfl team's coach
whenever they go to him october septem
you know november december saying hey
you know you want to you want to bail
when the season's over and you got to do
it right away before there's a playoff
game you know it's it's insane the whole
thing's insane and i don't know why
everyone's cool with that like they
don't want to that's that's that's the
problem rich to see the nfl nfl has
structure nfl they got a union like we
college they they have a governing body
the college football does not have a
governing body i mean that that was
exposed when kobe hit when the pandemic
hit we thought the ncaa was the
governing body like no you conferences
y'all on your own do what you want to do
so
we don't have a governing body we don't
have a union we don't have structure so
that's why it's like the wild wild west
right now and you have so i can i can go
on and on about that but that's the
foundation of of what's the the biggest
problem right now in college football
and then these coaches salaries these
contracts that they're signing oh rich
this is this is about to start to get
really crazy out there you know they're
signing contracts that are worth more
than nfl coaches so you want everything
that nfl has except you don't want the
same structure you don't want to give
these these student athletes because
they're quote-unquote amateurs the same
rights or the same type of uh even even
you don't even give them a union because
if you get them a union then you now you
have the issues um that that that that
are plaguing college football you will
have someone to address these issues now
as a group which they do not want
uh last two for you um you you want to
say who you you think should be a
husband trophy winner who would you vote
for who do you think
oh no i never say that before the war
comes out not never i i'll say like who
the finalists should go forward
so who should the finalists be who
should the finals be who the guy will
win it um well aidan hutchinson i think
should be a finalist i think that um
uh bryce young i mean listen i'm a guy
who is not just what you do because i
know these guys they can pat pad numbers
and pass stats against you know weaker
opponents which they do all the time but
it's also more importantly to me who you
do it again so it's not just what you do
but who you do it against and for him to
have a game he had um
against george st chapter game is good
just like aden hutchinson i mean three
sacks against ohio state the biggest
game in the regular season boom and um
third guy
i'm not sure um i mean
you can maybe throw in
hassan haskins kenny
desmond if it's picket can they can they
redo the trophy instead of it being a
stiff arm it's a fake slide can they do
that can they immediately get that
trophy made nice
how gangster was that move i mean
it's just and it's taking advantage to
be honest with you it's taking advantage
of the um the climate in college
football right now which is don't hit
the quarterback so
if if a guy looks like even looks like
he's about to go down guys pull up
automatically because they don't want to
get a targeting file or a personal file
or nothing like that so they they always
they're gonna pull up
and then he he does that he takes
advantage of the of the rule and uh runs
for an actual touchdown doing it too i
said hot damn look at this here
that's what i thought i said he just
wrote a check that uh you know if i'm
mel tucker and uh i'm telling the
spartans like don't target but go for it
and i'll deal with the refs afterwards
exactly
exactly that's what i will say
that's what i'm saying that's what i
tell my defensive staff and that's what
i tell the players go for it don't use
your helmet but go for it and then i'll
deal with it uh last one for you do you
think we got a shot what do you think
the whole thing the whole enchilada what
do you think permission absolutely yeah
absolutely i'm not just saying this as
you know because i went to school but i
know as an analyst yes please that's
what i do that's right that's what i
want that's the analyst what do you
think
yeah now do i got time to go into it or
you just wonder don't go for it no yes
okay yeah yeah yeah so georgia you know
the georgia's number one defense in the
country all year long and i did a tape
on saturday i talked about alabama's
white house i said john metchi i said
jamison williams they're going to have
to be the difference because
all the talk about the defense of the
front seven we never really talked about
their their secondary and their back end
and so what bill o'brien did offensive
coordinator alabama did which was
brilliant he found a way to neutralize
that front seven so once you neutralize
the front seven now you put the the
pressure on the back end on the
secondary and they carved them up bro
man they just they just ate them alive
and jamison williams had a had a hell of
a day so anyway with that being said
i believe that josh goddess the
offensive coordinator in michigan
if you've really paid attention he's in
a hell of a rhythm right now
he's in a hell of a rhythm and i also
think that michigan's defense
is
people are going to say ah mitch going
to line up and and and punch you in the
mouth that's what they want to do
that's not
what we want to do but that's what they
want to do but that's what they can do
and what if you allow them to do what
they're going to do but they're multiple
michigan's offenses very very multiple
most coordinators will tell you if you
got to prepare for two quarterbacks
that's a headache well you got to
prepare for cave mcnamara and you also
gotta prepare for this freshman j.j
mccarthy
you gotta prepare for three running
backs you got blake coral who's who's
lightning you got hassan as haskins
who's thunder but then you get donovan
edward how good is that kid how good is
that kid come on now you kidding me and
they used this kid in the championship
game for a double pass that's right and
he also grabbed one with one arm two i
know so now you got three on the back
you got two legitimate titans both them
in the championship game making one hand
one-handed grabs
both tight ends and then you got white
house it's like you got three or four
white house all of them can make plays
like and they use multiple personnel
groupings multiple sets and then they'll
slow it down for you they're getting
information
okay this you know clap his hands and
they'll look to the sideline
and then they'll get to play so my point
is
this is going to be a huge challenge for
for for georgia's defense because it's
just so much that they can do
offensively and so much to defend and
then i'm not sure people are really
impressed with georgia's offense
especially on the stetson bennett
against alabama and michigan has a
pretty pretty good defense to mike
mcdonald first year d for the
coordinator it came from uh the
baltimore ravens has been doing an
outstanding job to the point where he
actually out coached
ryan day and people aren't giving these
the uh
jim harbaugh
and mcdonald and that staff enough
credit for how they out coached ohio
state a couple of weeks ago in that game
dez i love you thanks for the time let's
do it again let's do it again right back
at you one of my favorite gold blue one
of my favorite humans on the planet
desmond howard hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here